CARTER MORGAN: Today,
we're talking about I/O AI,
and choosing your own
journey to the Cloud.
I'm Carter Morgan and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
The 2021 Google
I/O Developer event
will be held virtually
from May 18 to 20.
Connect with developers
from around the world
at this year's virtual Google
I/O for thoughtful discussions,
hands-on learning
with Google experts,
and a first look at our
latest developer products.
Don't forget to register and
check out the I/O 2021 puzzle.
Machine learning
plays a crucial role
in surveilling and measuring
the biodiversity of wildlife
in a non-invasive way.
On this episode of
"People and Planet AI,"
we show you how to create
an image classification
app for wildlife camera chats
with the help of Dataflow
and Google Cloud's
AI platform, Unified.
Watch and learn how you can
create an application that
tracks wildlife biodiversity.
Rather than wait for
budget alert emails,
you can use programmatic
budget notifications
to send budget updates to
your favorite comms channels
like Slack.
Check out this guide on how
to set up a Cloud function
and transform your budget
notifications into code.
Once you're working
with code, there's
no limit to what you can do.
Choose your own Cloud Adventure.
You get to make choices for the
engineers at the new startup
Eat and Run that specializes
in pairing runners
with the best food options
while they're on the go.
Now that the company has gained
national attention and user
traffic is skyrocketing, they
need your help to succeed.
Should they scale up
their back-end services
or speed up the delivery
of their assets?
The choice is up to you.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.